wow what a room
who wouldn't want to be here tonight
good evening and welcome to the 13th
Governor's Awards
once a year we 54 Academy Governors come
together for one of the most exalted and
privileged tasks of our tenure
to identify a handful of individuals
from all disciplines within our industry
who are particularly beloved and revered
we aim to fet them in the most
unadulterated fashion among their peers
and colleagues and away from Curious
onlookers
it's a special evening reserved solely
for our honorees
the meetings where we decide on the
recipients of the governor's Awards
often run on for many hours and in
gender heated discussion
this year not so much
when the names of the four individuals
who are being honored were raised there
was an immediate swell of recognition of
their merits
this year's recipients are truly varied
and remarkable in their own way
yuzan palsi
you're an incredible crowd I just have
to say
Diane Warren
Peter Weir
and last but certainly not least Michael
J fox
all right
talents are honored for their s for
stirring our imagination and our
creativity and one extraordinary
humanitarian celebrated for connecting
with our sense of conscience and
conviction
their big moments will come later this
evening but I want to first take a
moment to acknowledge the governors here
tonight representing our 17 branches
thank you for your tireless work
throughout the year
I have the deepest respect for all of
you and I'm honored to represent you
will you please stand up so that others
May recognize you as well
I just love this crowd so much you guys
are amazing
special thanks to Jennifer Fox the
veteran producer of tonight's show
as this is her fourth time doing so and
as you can see it only gets better
all because of you and I'd also like to
take a moment to thank Rolex for its
generous support of the academy and our
Museum all year round
[Applause]
our members today are more engaged than
ever
we are committed to refreshing and
rebranding with the academy and the
Oscars mean to movie fans around the
world and we have eyes fixed firmly on
the future
fortunately we have found a person
uniquely qualified to steer the ship our
magnificently talented CEO Bill Kramer
he along with his supremely dedicated
staff at both the academy and the museum
gives me utter confidence that we will
continue to be the home base for Global
movie fans and the next generation of
collaborative artists stream
our 10 000 Plus members please more
Applause sure why not
our 10 000 Plus members make for a true
Community bonded by a passion for
something that transcends time and place
Cinema is both a mirror for the world
around us as well as a powerful tool to
help shape the World As We would like it
to be
in the end we continually Inspire each
other to do better and do more
and so now let's raise the glass to four
of the most inspiring individuals who
are with us tonight
and to the knowledge that they have
filled us with wonder and faith that the
future of film and the world is
undeniably bright cheers
[Applause]